Your tag is probably the
most important element.
I look for one high-visibility
spot, and I put my name up.
50-something years of
working with this medium.
I've lived many lives.
Grew up as "Lenny."
Recently became "Leonard, Futura,
Futura 2000, Futura Dos Mil."
But I will answer
to "Yo", no problem.
I'm part of a school of art and
a culture that invented itself.
The movement left a legacy.
Things that were
emerging in the 80s
were beginning to open our
eyes up beyond the subway.
To me, the abstraction always
appeared inside the letters,
and what I was saying is, like,
"Wow, what if you took the letter away?"
So in this class, I'm
going to teach you
how to use spray paint.
I would say that can
is sufficiently shaken.
How to paint this line,
the thickness of that.
Spraying upside down,
that's essentially
how I'm able to control
the width of my lines.
I'm going to walk through
the creation of a painting,
and I'm also going to talk
about my world of abstraction,
and how that might apply
for you and your work.
Find your own techniques.
I'm going to try to follow
that line, and there you go.
1970, my mom came
to me with a story:
"We're not your
biological family."
I got an identity crisis.
It's the age-old
question, "Who am I?"
The graffiti thing that was
happening outside my door
seemingly was an answer.
I could hide under the
anonymous pseudonym
of this new character.
That's the impetus for me
becoming the graffiti writer
that I became.
Don't be deterred by what
may or may not be a mistake.
If I were suddenly like,
"Oh, no, what did I do?"
Hey, it's no problem.
Canvases can be repainted white.
Do something you think
you can't do,
and you might surprise yourself.
I just invented that.
I never did that before.
If someone like me found my
way, you should have no problem.
You don't even need a canvas
to paint or a wall to tag.
All you need is an idea
and a can of spray paint.
I'm Futura, and this
is my MasterClass.